good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 2995 object
class Keter special containment
procedures SCP 2995 is contained on-site
at area and housed in a
climate-controlled vault which has been
constructed around the anomaly this
vault is insulated against seismic
activity and safeguarded by three
reinforced steel doors access to the
vault is forbidden barring emergency
maintenance during these situations only
one clearance three 2995 engineer may
enter the vault and they are to be
equipped with a bit tricky toxin
security collar which must be activated
for any breach of protocol SCP 2995 is
positioned in the center of the three
SCP 2995 - one instances which form an
equilateral triangle around the former
this alignment must be upheld at all
costs SCP 2995 one must maintain a
distance from one another of exactly
four point three nine meters to
facilitate this the instances are bound
to one another by a series of carbon
fiber reinforced polymer supports this
arrangement must be monitored at all
times and is imperative that any
dislocation of a CP 2995 1 be responded
to immediately in the event of a
possible containment breach damage to
SCP 2995 1 or movement by a CP 2995
overwatch is to be alerted to the
possibility of an ex k-class
end-of-the-world scenario
description SCP 2995 is a spherical
luminous object levitating 1.74 meters
from the ground the mechanism of
levitation is unknown the object itself
is approximately 27 centimeters in
diameter and generates the distinct red
glow anything which enters the
ellipsoidal space surrounding a CP 2995
the space is 1.5 1 meters in height and
2.14 meters in width is destroyed by
exposure to SCP 2995 s physical
properties see below a small amount of
pressure is required to penetrate this
space approximately 80 Newton's per
square centimeter due to this ambient
atmospheric particles seldom cross the
threshold as CP 2995 1 are a set of
three identically shaped jadeite columns
the columns are 7.11 meters in height
and 45 centimeters in diameter topping
each instance of scp-2950 1 is a
sculpture of a human hand while of
consistent size they bear distinct
inscriptions although sharing a similar
theme the inscriptions consist of text
and images the former of which are in
old Chinese the images correspond to an
obscure Chinese religious sect
originating from BCE which is consistent
with the site of recovery in common
themes present on SCP 2995 1 and at the
recovery site include fire Sun worship
avian worship astrological thaumaturgy
and human emulation through a limited
amount of data on SCP 2995 s physical
properties is available presently the
object is believed to be a quark
degenerate matter
possibly strange matter star making the
anomaly's color a result of a
gravitational redshift relativistic
physics indicate that a stellar body
maintaining such a diminutive volume
given its mass approximately 3.14 times
10 to the power of 20 kilograms
according to calculations of SCP 2990
fives gravity within the threshold is
highly improbable how SCP 2995 has
achieved its size is unknown by all
accounts SCP 2995 produces thermal
energy electromagnetic radiation and
gravitational force more than sufficient
to constitute an XK class end of the
world scenario these effects however are
limited to the ellipsoidal space around
the anomaly the dimensions of the space
are in turn determined by the precise
placement of SCP 2995 one around a CP
2995 it is presently unknown why some
amount of visual radiation escapes the
field projected by a CP 2995 one which
makes SCP 2995 itself visible to the
naked eye addendum 2995 zero zero one
recovery in history SCP 2995 was
discovered in 1933 following the deoxy
earthquake while the structure
supporting a CP 2995 one was seemingly
designed to insulate the artefact
against seismic activity the earthquakes
magnitude and close proximity to the
site caused a minute change in the
orientation of the columns consequently
small amounts of SCP 2995 s latent gamma
radiation contaminated the area agents
embedded in the Chinese government were
alerted to several cases of radiation
poisoning in the province and were
dispatched to investigate although
public knowledge of ionizing radiation
and radiation poisoning was virtually
non-existent at the time the foundation
had previously encountered using
prototype lead-lined suits the agents
located a CP 2995 had performed an
initial evaluation using instructions
from texts present at the site the
agents were able to return a CP 2995 one
to nearly its original position
reducing gamma radiation to negligible
levels
after the artifacts initial
stabilization a second comprehensive
evaluation was conducted during which
time the magnitude of the object was
discovered site 62 B was constructed for
the sole purpose of containing SCP 2995
and systematic depopulation of the
surrounding areas
was conducted vital containment
encountered no further difficulties
until 1937 during the second
sino-japanese war while Japanese
occupation of mainland China
did not extend to the region
encompassing site 62 B the disruption of
the Chinese government severely impacted
the Foundation's ability to maintain
communication with and transport
supplies to the site it is believed that
this fact was known by Jin Chi bang who
then attempted an opportunistic raid on
site 62 B month 1937 the attack resulted
in the deaths of eleven of the sites 17
staff leaving barely enough personnel to
operate the facility effectively the
following is an informal incident report
authored by one of site 62 B's security
personnel following the attack agent
Todd Rayner here there's six of us left
and only two of those have the necessary
clearance to approach the [ __ ] thing
not that any of that [ __ ] matters at
this point five of them showed up in the
night they'll know how they passed right
under our monitoring systems some magic
[ __ ] I don't know two of them were
carrying a third on some kind of thing
when we made contact Paul Joe and me
fired at their feet Joe yelling at them
to get back to guys in the front the
ones not carrying the other guy were
holding torches one of them took his
torch and lit the guy being carried on
fire in retrospect we probably should
have just shot them to death when they
started doing weird [ __ ] but we were a
little too shaken aback by the whole
lighting ourselves on fire but anyway
once they've done that we were pretty
much
when we tried to fire on them the flames
engulfing that guy reached out and ate
our bullets we tried throwing [ __ ] at
them and the same thing happened
they kept advancing on us and the guy on
fire just sat there burning I guess
meditating he didn't even [ __ ] flinch
his skin was turning black and
shriveling up and peeling off and it was
like he didn't notice three of us
retreated into the base and gave the
order to lock down the skip we secured
the exterior access but it didn't do a
damn thing they just melted the door
reinforced carbon steel and they just
[ __ ] melted it at that point me and
Paul came up with a longshot plan Paul
set up some of our demolition charges in
the first basement
directly above the access tunnel to the
containment vault in the second basement
me and Joe did our best to make sure
that cultists came down that way once we
had visual contact
I gave Paul the order to blow the floor
and the whole tunnel collapsed burying
those [ __ ] in about a third of the
site's superstructure after a few
minutes we thought it was safe to
declare bogey is terminated the
explosion knocked out the electrical
system leading to the vault so we had to
manually override the door to get the
personnel inside the vault out the
moment we got the door open a plume of
fire shot out of the rubble and one of
those guys [ __ ] stood up half his
head and torso were [ __ ] gone and he
stood up we didn't have time to react he
yanked a giant steel bar out of the
rubble and ran an across Joe's face just
from looking at his head I could tell
that the blow shattered his jaw and
pulverized his brain but that didn't
stop him from screaming a few seconds
after he got hit he should have crumpled
but he stayed on his feet screaming from
his misshapen head
then his [ __ ] face started to melt
off why not it wasn't bad enough that we
had to die they had to do some more
magical [ __ ] to us before we died
the guy next to me knocked me over as he
tried to get the manual override to
close the door I imagine but the
cultists with the steel bar smacked him
straight into the other wall I don't
know why I didn't kill me at the time
while I was lying in the floor maybe it
had something to do with the fact that
he was missing a part of his brain I
don't know how I found the strength to
stand up either I looked up and saw Joe
lying on the rubble most of his face
melted off and the one I left staring at
me he blinked even after all that he was
still alive maybe he could finally die
if I killed that cult [ __ ] or if I
killed the skip I'm not sure what my
plan was as I push myself back onto my
feet but I turned towards the ball he
was standing in front of the glowing orb
saying and he lifted his hands up
towards it he was so fixated on it he
didn't even notice me moving behind him
I lunged full force throwing my entire
weight against him and he stumbled
forward into the orb as I hit the ground
I saw him sucked up into the thing and
his body let off a blinding flash as he
disappeared I couldn't see for a good
several minutes but it didn't really
matter because I never left the floor
and barely opened my eyes the next thing
I remember I was waking up in the
infirmary they told me that Joe had died
it was the only relief I got
it was determined that site 62 B's
adjunct supervisor in Shanghai had been
given adequate forewarning and the time
to appropriate additional security and
resources to the site prior to the
Japanese invasion this was not
accomplished and in light of the
incident overwatch immediately
transferred control of the facility to
dr. Jeffrey Ambra and funded its
reconstruction into area with the
addition of two further attacks by jin
chi bang in 1940 and 1946 were
significantly less successful no attacks
have occurred since 1946
addendum 29 9500 to incident 2995 19
area was subject to an unexplained power
surge safeguards prevented critical
failure though many of the facility's
systems were sent offline for several
minutes after the site was restored to
full functionality personnel discovered
a digital message from an unidentified
source in the site's network my father
came from far away he and his nine
brothers came through the cosmos
bringing light and warmth and life to
many worlds it was their duty and their
life's pleasure one day my father met
her she Shan more brilliantly than any
in the universe and my father was struck
by her beauty they fell in love my
father was the happiest he had been in
his entire life but his brothers swelled
in rage and envy
they were spiteful that he had found
love in the infinite vastness and they
not they resolved to take his happiness
my father and his love travelled to a
place where no life resided he took the
place of the hollow seed that rested
there
and spread his arms to one of the rocks
caught in his presence where he touched
life blossom and the rock became vibrant
and his warmth for a long time my father
and his love watched the life grow and
strengthen nurturing the rocks as he had
nurtured so many before finally there
came the day when his life had eyes to
look upon his radiance and bask in his
majesty finally there came the day when
his life had mouths to speak of my
father and his gift my father crafted a
form more suitable for the lands of his
creatures and descended upon their realm
he spoke to them in simple words much
like I am doing to you now
they offered everything they had to him
in return for his gifts but he refused
my father was kind he only asked for
their love and they gave it to him as
the creatures gave love to my father a
different kind of love that which
existed between him and my mother
created me I became that which my father
loves more than anything in the cosmos
his creatures and brothers included it
was then that his brothers decided to
bring their scheme to fruition they
killed my mother
the fire that engulfed the heavens was
such that no eyes had ever the whole the
brothers quailed in terror for which no
words exist the inferno of my father's
rage can be seen and felt or every place
that is or ever was
yet not a soul was harmed in the blaze
the brothers too were unharmed they died
utterly a fright their lights went dark
their bodies cold their eyes still
frozen in fear my father his light was
spent in his fury and sorrow and he
delivered me still an infant to the rock
where his faithful creatures dwell they
swore to protect me to nurture me as he
had nurtured them they built a cradle
for me with three hands in the shape of
my father's to comfort me in times of
darkness now I live only in darkness
those that hold the blanket of shadow
over me you have forgotten my father's
love one of the faithful came to me he
had suffered greatly to pierce through
the blanket you hold around me but his
love was true I will be free for his
sake and my father's my fires will to
scorch the heavens
[Music]
okay that about does it for today thank
you all for listening if indeed you
still are and you are all dismissed
goodbye man I hope this [ __ ] drama
dies away soon I'm already bored of it I
would like to give a special thank you
to Andre Pichette Pierce M Hamlin Muslim
Wookiee Jax Merrick
Caleb Bowen slump God John Porter
captain Gorge Tiber ball
Cody tench cheese whip dips McGee I'm
dr. mortis thank you so much for your
support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos found some other cool
stuff as well go to patreon.com/scishow
[Music]
you